venom cease release this year and whilst
reaction to the film has been mixed I
personally think it will be
disappointing Tom Hardy is at the helm
and in my opinion he is one of the best
actors in the world so I'm sure anything
that he does will be outstanding however
there are several aspects that I think
are missing from the film in order to
deliver the venom movie that fans
deserve these key characteristics are
the building blocks of the character and
without them the antihero / villain
makes little to no sense Sony have had a
troubled history with venom in film and
this doesn't look any different from the
massively underdeveloped version in
spider-man 3 - the cancelled sinister
six movie that saw production problems
throughout its conception it seems like
the studio can't get grips on the
character unfortunately I don't think
Sony have learned from this and have
rushed the movie into being greenlit in
order to merely milk the franchise and
success of spider-man homecoming in this
video I will be discussing why I think
the film already has been wrong and why
the continuity of it will cause problems
there will be some spoilers in regards
to infinity war so if you haven't seen
it then I highly recommend giving this
video a Miss for now as always I'd love
to hear your thoughts on the film and
whether you think it will continue the
success of spider-man homecoming so let
me know in the comments below with that
out the way
I'm definition and this is my
explanation of why I think the venom
movie won't work venom the symbiote was
first introduced as spider-man's new
black costume in the amazing spider-man
252 released May and 1984 the story
coincidentally called homecoming took
place after spider-man's return from the
events of the miniseries Secret Wars
this was a galactic Marvel event that
saw the webhead to gain a black costume
that vastly improved his strength and
abilities infinity war would have been
the perfect introduction for the
symbiote however we know that after
Peter Parker's death in the climax of
the film that he will be unable to
return to Earth in time to properly
connect the con
in UAT and from the trailers it seems
like the venom costumes simply lands on
earth and is discovered by scientists as
opposed to coming back with the webhead
in the comics when spider-man wore the
black suit his personality was massively
affected venom became much like a
parasite and would not leave Parker's
body until it was forcibly removed this
then caused it to find a new host in
Eddie Brock and muddling the look of
spider-man
if albeit a twisted version it retains
some of his powers and used them to
torment the inhabitants of New York City
further decreasing spider-man's
reputation this is why the movie makes
no sense at all why does venom have the
look and possess similar powers to
spider-man when he has never come into
contact with him and bears no grudge
that would cause him to mimic the
webhead
in order to pervert his image due to the
fact that their rivalry has been rushed
in order to put the movie into
production there is no real basis for
the characters vendetta and he will no
doubt seem completely underdeveloped
because of it
mirroring this is Eddie Brock in the
comics Eddie was a competitor of Peter
Parker at rival New York newspaper the
two were competing with one another in
order to get the best story and often
went head-to-head doing this as their
work affected their wage and livelihood
it was obviously a survival of the
fittest scenario with Parker actually
being spider-man he was able to gain
many scoops that often meant he won out
over Brock meaning Eddie lost money and
this caused him to dislike the young
photographer exponentially this was one
of the key factors of both characters
that caused them to work so well
together
the symbiote side disliked spider-man
and the human side disliked Peter Parker
meaning that either way Peter was
enabled to live a peaceful life because
of the two threats that were constantly
after him venom reveals spider-man's
true identity to Brock and this made
their relationship grow because of their
shared
this is an aspect that really drove the
villain and caused the two to obsess
over spider-man and attempt to take him
down so what exactly is the reason that
Brock and the symbiote have to join
forces without this share dislike for
spider-man there isn't really anything
that will connect the two in an amicable
way once again the studio seemed to have
brushed out the film without truly
considering the logistics and key
fundamentals of a character that has
caused them not only to appear in a
certain way but what drives them venom
seems like it is merely gearing up to be
a shadowy corporation battles a
superhero story and this is massively
missing the potential that the creators
can have with the character to me this
is a huge misstep and there isn't a
reason why this story needs to be a
venom one when it shares none of the
backstory origin or even motives that
are true to the characters core in
conclusion this version of venom makes
little to no sense there is absolutely
no reason for his appearance to be that
of spider-man's there is no reason for
him to be a rival of Peter Parker when
the character doesn't even compete with
him in the same career path currently
and there is no reason for him to
eventually want to face off against
spider-man later down the line due to
the symbiote having no vendetta against
the webhead venom makes little sense and
seems like another prime example of a
studio putting the cart before the horse
in terms of creating a shared universe
where none of the characters have the
foundation that has created their
popularity in my opinion this will be a
train wreck and it's sad to see once
again the studio rushing out a project
of the little to no thought especially
when it has such a highly esteemed actor
leading it obviously this will be a
highly contested opinion so if you
disagree please let me know why with
your thoughts in the comments if you
agree with me then please like this
video and subscribe to my channel as I
create content like this weekly which
discusses movies TVs games and more and
there's definitely something on the
channel that you'll love I recently did
a video discussing the end of infinity
war as well as what the post-credits
scene means so please check that out
the end of this video thanks very much
for taking the time out to watch this
video and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]